now we'd like to talk about angular
velocity so for a particle traveling in
a circle we've seen that the velocity
can be written as R d theta/dt
in the theta hat direction and we've
also seen that D theta DT can be
positive in which case theta is
increasing and so the particle is
traveling around the circle in this
direction you can call that the
counterclockwise direction we've also
seen that D theta DT can be negative in
which case the angle is decreasing so
the particle is traveling around the
circle in this direction which we could
call a clockwise let's now look at
rotation in an arbitrary plane so if I
have a plane like this and I have some
particle traveling in a circle like this
and I have some observer that's above
the plane looking down on this plane
then it will see the this rotation as
being in the counterclockwise direction
whereas if I have another observer down
here and they're looking up at this
plane they'll see the motion as being
clockwise and so you can see we have a
need for the more formal definition for
the rotation of this and so what we're
going to do is use the right hand rule
to define a direction that tells you
both the direction it defines the plane
and it also tells you what the positive
direction of rotation is for that plane
so the way we'll do this right hand rule
is we'll take our right hand we'll curl
our fingers in the direction of the
rotation and our thumb will point in the
direction of that positive the the
positive direction that we're defining
so in this case I'm gonna have an arrow
like this I'll call it n hat to indicate
that it's the normal unit vector to that
plane all right let's come back to this
example now where the plane of the
motion is this plane of the board and
let's look at our two cases again so in
the case of d theta/dt
positive
our circle looks something like this
and you can see that if I use my right
hand rule the plane the vector that I've
defined is out of the board and I'm
going to use this symbol a circle with a
dot to indicate this direction of out of
the board in our other case for d
theta/dt less than zero our particle is
traveling in this direction and so you
can see by my right hand rule that now
the part of the that direction that I've
defined is into the board and for that
I'm going to draw this as an X in a
circle so these are symbols that you'll
see throughout the rest of the course
the end the out of the board and into
the board symbols and so now let's look
back at our coordinate system that we've
defined we have an R hat direction and a
theta hat direction and in this
coordinate system there's a third
direction that's defined which is the K
hat direction which you can see is out
of the board and so now I'm gonna define
what we actually call the angular
velocity as Omega and I'm going to write
that as D theta DT now in the K hat
direction in this case it could be in an
arbitrary and hat direction depending on
what your plane of motion is in this
case I'm going to call it in the K hat
direction and now you can see that these
signs are gonna line up with these
directions so Omega as d theta/dt K hat
when D theta DT is positive K hat is in
the same direction as this unit normal
that we've defined that defines both the
plane of the motion and the direction of
the motion and when d theta DT is
negative I have that Omega is in the
negative K hat direction which is
exactly this direction here that we've
defined as being the motion for this
plane and so this is how we define
angular velocity so we can define the k2
DT to be the component of the angular
velocity Omega Z because it's in the K
hat direction
and we can also define the angular speed
which we write as just Omega as being
the absolute value of this angular
velocity Omega so that is in other words
it's just the absolute value of d
theta/dt so when a particle is
undergoing circular motion it has a
velocity that you can describe which is
the tangential motion around the circle
and it's also it also has an angular
velocity which we define as being in a
direction that's perpendicular to that
direction of rotation and it's defined
by the right-hand rule and now that we
have defined this Omega Z the angular
component of the angular velocity we can
rewrite the velocity as just being equal
to R times Omega Z still in that theta
hat direction and so this is another way
that we can write the velocity and
connect it back to the angular velocity